opposers when it comes to immigration
this country is built on rules the rule
of law the rules of engagement 8 simple
rules for dating my teenage daughter fun
fact
Roy mores favorite sitcom but
you can google it but don't trust google
Oh be a big man but illegal immigrants
aren't following the rules which is why
just three weeks ago Whitehouse Stuart
little Jeff sessions dust it off as
tough guy bifocals and laid down the law
sessions made it crystal clear that
prosecutors at the Justice Department
are going to have a policy of zero
tolerance at the border if you're
smuggling a child then we're gonna
prosecute you and that child will be
separated from you probably as required
by law if you don't want your child to
be separated then don't bring them
across the border illegally yes exactly
if you don't want to lose your child to
the government don't bring them across
the border and if you don't want to lose
them to drug cartels don't stay where
you are it's like an immigrant catch-22
which is also Isis hourly quota fine I
know I know it's hard it's hard to meet
the 22 but they do it they do it
finally America is taking off the gloves
because fear is a great deterrent it
leaves a lasting impression see I used
to leave post-it notes so my coworker
Todd wouldn't steal my lunch but the
theft didn't stop until I added a
Polaroid of him sleeping
it worked the snowflakes on the left
think this tactic is callous or
unamerican just listen to Warby Parker
jr. chief of staff John Kelly told NPR
just last week that separating families
would be quote a tough deterrent adding
the children will be taken care of put
into foster care or whatever put into
foster care or whatever shut up boy
detective
he said foster care or whatever whatever
could be anywhere like a sick house boat
or a Dave & Buster's with free skee-ball
or a Magic School Bus but instead of
going inside the human body it takes
babies down to Guatemala now of course
the bleeding-heart New York Times says
the president's policy of breaking up
immigrant families makes children more
vulnerable to exploitation and abuse and
creates toxic stress that can profoundly
impact their development and the New
York Times knows toxic stress everyone
in that office has gotten roped into
going to one of Maggie Haberman acapella
shows
luckily President Trump is holding the
right people accountable other people
President Trump is blaming Democrats
were separating immigrant children from
their parents saying quote put pressure
on the Democrats to end the horrible law
that separates children from their
parents once they cross the border into
the US but to be clear the president is
referring to his own administration's
policy that's right it's his own
administration's policy and Democrats
are to blame
what's so confusing about that yep
maybe my trusty Gaslight can shed some
light on this where was I oh yes that
Trump policy of separating children from
their families that's the Democrats
fault it's always been the Democrats
fault you remember history Abraham
Lincoln was a Republican but Osama bin
Laden was a Democrat why aren't more
people talking about that I'm not sure
check this light
Democrats hate immigrants they won't
even protect the dreamers why are the
dreamers in trouble again who remembers
you don't look at the Gasland the
Democrats control everything they're
only pretending to lose at every level
of governments you know when you're at a
friend's house and you pet their dog
wrong and it yelps which makes everyone
think you're mean to dogs Democrats did
that
[Music]
so come on Democrats then step it up and
fix all America's problems because the
last year has been chock-full of them
for some reason the fight continued